des clients qui sont récurrents nos
établissements et qui viennent prendre
un café
le matin qui reviennent des jeunes et
qui peut même éventuellement des dîners
ce qui est le cas d'ailleurs de tous les
clients de l'hôtel en général qui sont
ni pension ou pension complète pour leur
éviter de redemander le pass 10 fois
dans la journée on a imaginé leur faire
porter un bracelet
merci beaucoup à partir du moment où ses
clients nous ont présenté leurs passes
sanitaire vaccinale et c'est à dire le
passe avec deux doses et qu'ils ont
justifié leur d'identité on considère
qu' il se passe sanitaire est valable et
on peut leur imposer ce bracelet qui est
un bracelet à usage unique qu'on peut
garder autant de temps qu'on veut et qui
permet de rentrer et de sortir dans
l'est dans l'établissement c'est pour
faciliter effectivement l'accès de nos
clients de nos établissements encore une
fois c'est pas sanitaire a fait baisser
sensiblement l'activité de certains
établissements d'autres très
sensiblement c'est vrai que le jeune
public par exemple qui est moins
vacciner
peut en avoir ras-le-bol de se faire
tester à tester ces bracelets qui sont
au nombre de vingt mille donc il ya
globalement 20 établissements qui vont
se voir s'embrasser se voit cela se
dessine vraiment quand une fois aux
clients récurrents et qui sont les
habitués de ces établissements
non
c'est un peu compliqué au niveau de la
gestion
avec le service ça nous maintient en
fait une personne à l'accueil après
non on n'a pas le choix là haut niveau
des bracelets justement c'est une
facilité ce sera ça sera beaucoup plus
rapide pour nous on aura moins de perte
de temps à vérifier
je pense que ça genre dont beaucoup plus
envie
ça sera plus rapide
[Musique]
où